how everyone's Jerry this is another
live blitz game okay we have a 1967
opponent will try e4 it's been a while
since I did a blitz game first run in
the new year so hopefully it's a good
one
Alekhine's defense this is the first
time that I'm facing this I'm gonna
shoot for the four pawns attacks I
really don't know when - too much about
this I know that my Center is going to
come under a lot of fire with d6 and I'm
just going to try to maintain the center
the center that I'm building right now
one in one important thing that I am
aware of is that you don't want to
develop this knight to f3 prior to the
bishop coming to e3 if if you do do that
early then this Bishop couldn't come out
immediately to g4 and pin your knight
and it could be problematic so I'm just
going to lend some support to my d4 pawn
that's likely to come under a lot of
fire black and make natural developing
moves like knight c6 pressure on d4
Queen d7 as well as queenside castling
so I have to be a bit careful so what do
I do here I'm thinking either Bishop e2
or Knight f3 I think I'm gonna go with
Bishop e2 first I've played some
positions in this variation I've seen f6
eventually putting more pressure on my
center point in this case now e5 so
we've already seen d6 f6 may play a role
as well
Bishop to e7 I don't know if this is I
haven't really seen this I've seen Queen
d7 is followed by queenside castling
right away so not too too familiar with
just immediately Bishop e7 but I still
think this f6 advance is a good thing to
get in what's this
change of color scheme I didn't expect
that alright I'm in check here so I have
a computer issue I'm just gonna block
that check I don't think that that was
that great of a move okay so I mean
what's the drawback with g3 okay age
three is now weakened but is it worth
the time that was wasted as a result of
just throwing in this check and then
retreating
I'm not so sure I don't think that this
is too much of a problem for me I do
have this rook already on a half-open
file I think I'm ready to maybe start
pushing black around maybe as a result
of that little spite check so I'm
thinking d5 at this point what would
blacks response be if I did d5 I might
maybe have some pressure against c4
maybe Knight here but I could play b3
I'm gonna try this maybe make black pay
for that little waste of time so maybe
I'm in trouble all of a sudden actually
because ah what is going on with this
change the color scheme so now my clock
is ticking and I have to deal with this
color scheme thing all right let's see
change the color scheme did it don't
show this message again there we go okay
all right so the Knights getting ready
to come to see to forking these guys and
there's pressure against this pawn so
what do I do
how do I meet that threat how about
Knight d4 actually these two this is one
one point to make well I'm down on time
too so now this bishop is hitting my
rook so actually when the knight was on
c6 and my knight was on f6 one term
that's used to describe those knights
his counterparts so if the knight on c6
moves you'll often see in many instances
the knight on f3 move so maybe I better
just shut up and move because I'm
running out of time maybe my new year's
resolution should be to just move a bit
faster so actually if he takes here on
d5 I think I might have to flush this
night away first and only then maybe
capture on d5 let's give that a shot
do I want to do that yeah let's let's
chase this guy way I think I just end up
using a pond actually so oh let's see
maybe there's some sort of compensation
maybe can I trap this guy somehow
probably not all right it's not looking
good here let's just take this guy we'll
take it we'll take pieces first and then
think later maybe so I'm just going to
have to move
bit faster if I take like this actually
let's go for Knight takes Queen takes
Bishop Bishop f3 Queen takes pawn Bishop
takes pawn here would win up would win a
piece or maybe not because this pawn is
hanging so this is this is looking very
very ugly Queen takes pawn I'm down to
pawns this Bishop is sitting pretty nice
here although it's unprotected on h3 I
don't think I could really take
advantage of that I don't see really any
tactic that could come about maybe one
day the bishop coming to e4 and taking
on this square followed by Queen h5
check I don't see how that would be 2 2
good so the Queen's under fire I don't
know why this pawn wasn't just grabbed
maybe I'm just missing something all
right so first maybe let's chase this
queen around you know mate probably
taking here still good but I don't think
black would take it if they could have
taken down the previous move so there's
a little bit of psychology going on here
I doubt that this problem would be taken
or maybe actually maybe it should be now
because if you go here then there's a
discovered check or discovered attack
with the knight move the knight will be
protecting my bishop and the bishop
would be hitting the Queen so there we
go so now maybe I attack the Queen let's
do this meet the threat of Queen takes
Bishop and now this threat of Queen
takes pawn with a little fork is in the
air now what to do okay let's grab this
guy first and then think about stuff
later the rook is gonna come here put
pressure on my knight
maybe I move my bishop back defend the
threat against this guy and then what if
what do I do if the Queen comes here
alright this isn't good so do I want to
take the knight hmm no I'm in this pin
this is an awkward pin I don't like that
pin I want to get out of it as soon as
possible and I'm gonna want to move I'm
gonna move my queen
should I try an ending let's try it
let's try an ending I'm gonna go for
that I'm gonna recapture with my knight
oh this is a big blunder Oh
all right I lucked out with that one huh
I had to deal with those color scheme
issues so how do I meet this threat how
do I be as precise as possible if I take
the rook recaptures there's a little
fork that's probably still winning but
let's just let's just grab this guy here
and get rid of any any any dark square
problems maybe that was just a big
oversight by Wolfie all right let's see
I retreat the rook so a little bit of
technique hopefully should win this game
even though I'm down on time okay
I'm not sure what else to even comment
on here that was just a really serious
blunder but it happens it splits
let's bring the King closer to the
center I guess get this rook doing
something so I'm up I'm actually up a
full Queen so he should probably resign
soon maybe he's trying to win on time I
guess who knows maybe I'll get another
computer err and I'll have to do
something about that
all right just centralize my queen I
guess not - don't don't be afraid in
your own games if you're if you have a
material advantage don't be afraid to
give some of it back
- release any pressure on your own
position so hopefully the scylla resigns
soon I'll just take him actually and
then just run this pawn down that should
be good enough so passed pawns must be
pushed back to the fundamentals basic
stuff but that's easy to say when you're
up material huh rook b1 place your uh
piece behind the pass pawn so actually
just even if I didn't have my rook in
this position this would probably be
close to winning let's scoot my king out
of the way and then push the b-pawn away
okay no more checks
attack run the a pond down the a pond
could guard b7 and eventually Wolfie
should be resigning there we go okay so
that was pretty scary game had some
computer issues hopefully I could
resolve those sorts of things but that's
all for this video hope you got
something out of it take care bye